These days, movie fans are constantly bombarded
with trailers, posters, and new information
about all kinds of tentpole franchise films.
On the flip side, however, there are a few
upcoming movies that have managed to fly under
the radar.
From sci-fi epics to action-packed thrillers,
here are some of the sequels you might not
know are being made.
After years of speculation that a fourth Matrix
film was in the works, Variety broke the news
in August 2019 that a new instalment in the
series was indeed on the horizon, and that,
despite previous rumors, it wouldn't be following
a new character after all.
Original stars Keanu Reeves and Carrie Ann
Moss will be returning for The Matrix 4, along
with original writer and director Lana Wachowski.
"Woah."
And while Wachowski may have partnered with
her sister Lilly to make the first three Matrix
movies, the fourth installment will have only
the one Wachowski at the helm.
In addition to Wachowski, the script for The
Matrix 4 will be co-written by Aleksandar
Hemon and David Mitchell, and is set to start
production in early 2020.
No plot details have yet been revealed for
the movie, and it isn't yet clear how the
film plans to incorporate Moss' or Reeves'
characters, who were killed in the third film
in the franchise, The Matrix Revolutions.
It is equally unclear whether Laurence Fishburne's
character, Morpheus, will be making an appearance.
Some sources have speculated that he may be
recast in order to appear as a younger version
of the character, but that remains speculation
for now.
James Cameron has been talking about his Avatar
sequels almost from the moment the first film
exploded onto screens in 2009, smashing box
office records and eventually becoming the
highest-grossing film of all time.
However, despite years of Cameron's repeated
promises of a vast and expansive Avatar franchise,
it was beginning to feel as though a follow-up
was as far off and unreachable as the moon
of Pandora itself.
But believe it or not, four more Avatars really
do appear to be imminent.
In fact, according to Sigourney Weaver, the
first two have already finished shooting.
They've even got titles: Avatar: The Way of
Water, Avatar: The Seed Bearer, Avatar: The
Tulkun Rider, and Avatar: The Quest for Eywa.
What does it all mean?
Well, no one knows, except James Cameron himself
and his eclectic cast, which, in addition
to the original movie's stars, also features
a host of newcomers, including Edie Falco,
Kate Winslet, Michelle Yeoh, Jemaine Clement,
and Vin Diesel.
Everyone else will have to wait until the
end of 2021 to find out.
Avatar: The Way of Water is scheduled for
release on December 17th 2021, with
Avatar: The Seed Bearer arriving on December 22nd
2023, Avatar: The Tulkun Rider following on
December 19th 2025, and Avatar: The Quest
for Eywa concluding the franchise on December 17th 2027.
As the crew of the Nostromo learned the hard
way all the way back in 1979, it's pretty
hard to kill an Alien, and the Alien franchise
seems just as tough as the creature itself.
Reflecting on his landmark sci-fi horror film
on its 40th anniversary, director Ridley Scott
told Variety that a third prequel is indeed
on the way, intended as a follow-up to 2012's
Prometheus and 2017's Alien: Covenant.
Despite generally positive critical reviews,
Covenant underperformed at the box office,
throwing the future of the franchise into
uncertainty.
But following Disney's acquisition of Fox,
both Scott and Alien's new studio home seem
eager to return to the sinister stars yet
again.
As for what this third prequel might be about,
only one thing is for sure: it won't follow
the format of the original Alien.
Speaking to The Hollywood Reporter, Scott
talked about the need for the franchise to
continue to evolve in order to succeed.
He said:
"You can't keep repeating [the same premise]
because the joke gets boring."
This next Alien film, tentatively titled Alien:
Awakening, is still in the very early stages,
and none of the cast of Covenant has yet been
asked to return.
Still, Scott maintains three things: it's
happening, he'll be directing it, and it's
currently in the script phase.
After the release of the poorly-received Indiana
Jones and the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull,
no one would've blamed Harrison Ford, Steven
Spielberg, and everyone else at Lucasfilm
if they'd given up on the Indiana Jones franchise
altogether.
But now it appears that Indy will be back
with Indiana Jones 5, which, despite a number
of push-backs and delays, is still theoretically
happening.
Indiana Jones 5 has gone through a number
of screenwriters already, from Crystal Skull
scribe David Koepp, to Solo's Jonathan Kasdan,
to This Is Us creator Dan Fogelman, and now,
apparently, back to Koepp.
No word has yet been given on what Indiana
Jones 5 will be about, although Harrison Ford
will be at least 78 when the movie starts
filming, so chances are that the adventure
will have to be a little less physically rigorous
than previous installments.
"It's not the years, honey.
It's the mileage."
Of course, it's possible that even the filmmakers
don't quite know the movie's plot yet.
Speaking to Den of Geek in September of 2019,
Koepp said:
"I'm working on it again.
We're still trying.
And I think we've got a good idea this time.
We'll see."
If Indiana Jones 5 is indeed still hanging
around in the "good idea" stage, it's probably
got a long way to go before it actually hits
theaters.
Still, according to everyone involved, it'll
get there.
Eventually.
Bill may have finally been killed at the end
of 2004's Kill Bill Vol. 2, but that hasn't
stopped director Quentin Tarantino from expressing
his desire for another sequel to round out
the trilogy.
According to Tarantino, the third Kill Bill
would focus on the daughter of Vernita Green,
who is now all grown up and on the hunt for
revenge against the person who killed her
mother, Uma Thurman's Beatrix.
Tarantino has said that he's had talks with
Thurman about Kill Bill Vol. 3 as recently
as July of 2019, telling MTV:
"If any of my movies were going to spring
from my other movies, it would be a third
Kill Bill."
Of course, a third Kill Bill may throw a wrench
in Tarantino's plans to retire after his tenth
film; his ninth, Once Upon a Time in Hollywood,
hit theaters in the summer of 2019, and his
tenth, an upcoming Star Trek film, is currently
in the works.
Then again, no one but Tarantino himself is
going to hold him to his self-imposed film
cap if he chooses to keep going.
Nothing is finalized for a Kill Bill sequel
yet, but it seems as though all that would
be needed for it to materialize is simply
for Tarantino to decide to pull the trigger.
Although rumor has it that a third Sherlock
Holmes film has always been part of the plan
over at Warner Bros., Robert Downey Jr. has
spent the past decade leading the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as the genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist Tony Stark.
Saving the world every couple years is obviously
a pretty draining gig, and Downey's superhero
commitments kept him from being able to take
up Sherlock's trademark deerstalker and pipe
for a third time.
But now that Downey has seemingly exited the
MCU for good, he finally has the time to team
up with Watson, solve one more case, and take
his last bow as the famous detective.
The third Sherlock Holmes film will be helmed
by Rocketman director Dexter Fletcher, a departure
from the first two films, which were both
directed by Guy Ritchie.
While Sherlock Holmes 3 was originally scheduled
to release on Christmas Day 2020, it has since
been pushed back a year, and will now be striding
into theaters in December 2021.
The Hitman's Bodyguard wasn't exactly a critical
success, earning a pretty lousy Rotten Tomatoes score.
But the movie did pretty well at the box office,
pulling in almost $177 million worldwide against
a $30 million budget.
After all, how can an audience possibly say
no to the combined charisma of Ryan Reynolds
and Samuel L. Jackson?
Well, fans of the first film will be happy
to know that The Hitman's Bodyguard is getting
a sequel, confusingly titled The Hitman's
Wife's Bodyguard.
Reynolds and Jackson are both returning, and
Salma Hayek is also coming back at the titular wife.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, the plot
will find Reynolds' bodyguard trying to live
a peaceful life when he gets mixed up with
Jackson's hitman once more.
Along with Hayek, the trio will apparently
wreak havoc along the Amalfi Coast in an attempt
to save Europe from some as-yet-unconfirmed
threat.
The movie will also star familiar names like
Morgan Freeman, Antonio Banderas, Frank Grillo,
and Richard E. Grant.
If you're hoping for a wild time at the movies,
then this is the one for you; insiders are
describing this film as:
"The Good.
The Bad.
And the Bats--- crazy."
According to Deadline, RoboCop is indeed returning
to the big screen sometime soon, although
it seems this new film is going to mess around
with the franchise's continuity.
The original RoboCop was directed by Paul
Verhoeven, and it made quite a killing when
it was released in 1987.
After two sequels starring original actor
Peter Weller, the franchise was rebooted in
2014, with actor Joel Kinnaman and director
Jose Padilha.
The remake wasn't nearly as popular as the
first film, and sadly for Mr. Kinnaman, it
looks like the new movie is going to ignore
the recent remake altogether.
The latest entry in the franchise will be
called RoboCop Returns, and is written by
Ed Neumeier and Michael Miner, the guys who
penned the first film.
In fact, RoboCop Returns was apparently written
right after the original was released.
Sadly, the script never got made into a movie,
but now MGM is giving it another go, with
the help of some rewrites by Terminator: Dark
Fate writer Justin Rhodes.
Sadly, Peter Weller won't be returning to
reprise his robo-role.
As for the plot synopsis, Deadline writes:
"Anarchy reigns and the fate of Detroit hangs
in the balance as RoboCop makes his triumphant
return to fight crime and corruption."
Though District 9's Neill Blomkamp was initially
attached to direct, he announced in August
2019 that scheduling conflicts had forced
him to depart the project.
In November 2019, Orion Pictures announced
that Little Monsters director Abe Forsythe
had taken up the helm of RoboCop Returns,
and would also be giving the screenplay a
fresh rewrite.
"Your move, creep."
What do you get when you cross a horde of
hungry zombies with a very fast train?
A critically acclaimed blockbuster that desperately
needs a sequel, apparently.
Released in 2016, Train to Busan earned $85
million in its homeland of South Korea, and
wowed critics across the globe.
The plot follows a selfish businessman who's
taking his daughter on a train ride to the
city of Busan, when zombies suddenly start
popping up all over the place.
At first, the protagonist is only concerned
with protecting himself and his kid, but as
things get bloodier and bloodier, he starts
helping the other passengers escape the oncoming
horde.
Now, it seems writer-director Yeon Sang-ho
is working on part two, supposedly titled
Bando.
The English title is being reported to be
"Peninsula," which seems to imply that the
zombie virus has spread across Korea.
Shooting began in the summer of 2019, with
a new cast stepping in front of the camera.
It's evidently a good time to be in the zombie
train business, as New Line is currently working
on an American remake of the first film.
Of course, if you're new to the whole Train
to Busan phenomenon, you can prepare for both
the sequel and the reboot by checking out
the 2016 thriller in all its bloody glory
over on Netflix.
Sylvester Stallone and The Expendables 4 have
been engaging in a will-they-won't-they dance
for a few years now, but the latest signs
seem to point definitively to "they will".
Taking to his own Instagram account, Stallone
announced in July 2019 that the sequel was
back on, with a photo of the star in his Expendables
gear and the caption:
"All of those July 4th fireworks got my mind
going!
I am starting to cook up the next adventure!"
Stallone directed, co-wrote, and starred in
the original Expendables, which came out in
2010.
He also helped write the existing two sequels,
although for those, he handed off directorial
duties to Simon West for 2 and Patrick Hughes
for 3.
He walked away from The Expendables 4 back
in 2017, but his exit appears to have been
only temporary.
In addition to Stallone, the Expendables franchise
has been a veritable Who's Who of current
and former action superstars, but only Jason
Statham and Arnold Schwarzenegger have been
confirmed as joining Stallone in The Expendables
4.
"I'm back."
If and when Stallone does finalize the fourth
installment in the series, though, you can
expect the cast list to grow exponentially,
with an even more impressive collection of
stars than the previous three films.
After the runaway success of The Hunger Games
series of books and films, it seemed likely
that audiences would one day return to the
dystopian world of Panem, one way or another.
And sure enough, in June 2019, publisher Scholastic
announced that it would be releasing another
novel by Suzanne Collins set in the Hunger
Games world.
This book would be a prequel, set 64 years
before the events of the original story, and
would focus on the tenth Hunger Games.
In October 2019, the book's title was revealed:
The Ballad of Songbirds and Snakes.
Along with the announcement of the novel came
the confirmation that Collins' prequel will
also receive the movie treatment.
Lionsgate chairman Joe Drake, whose studio
adapted the Hunger Games films, said of the
book announcement:
"As the proud home of the Hunger Games movies,
we can hardly wait for Suzanne's next book
to be published.
We've been communicating with her during the
writing process and we look forward to continuing
to work closely with her on the movie."
The Ballad of Songbirds and Snakes is scheduled
to hit bookshelves on May 19th 2020, and from
the sounds of things, more news about the
film adaptation will be right on its heels.
Directed by the one and only John Carpenter,
Big Trouble in Little China is one of the
wackiest action movies ever made.
This 1986 fantasy-adventure follows trucker
Jack Burton as he attempts to save a kidnapped
woman from the dark and magical underbelly
of San Francisco's Chinatown.
With its Mortal Kombat-style warriors and
magical sword fights, Big Trouble in Little
China has become a beloved classic, so naturally
people were a bit worried when a remake with
Dwayne Johnson was announced in 2015.
There hasn't been a lot of new info since
then, but it's now clear that the new Big
Trouble will actually be a sequel.
Speaking to Collider, producer Hiram Garcia
admitted:
"You can't remake a classic like [Big Trouble],
so what we're planning to do is continue the story.
We're going to continue the universe of Big
Trouble in Little China."
As Garcia went on to explain, the events of
the first film will still exist in the new
Dwayne Johnson movie.
On top of that, the Rock will be playing a
brand new character, rather than Jack Burton.
So it seems they're taking a page from the
Jurassic World playbook, by crafting a movie
that exists in a pre-established timeline,
but also serves as a kind of reboot for a
new generation.
Unfortunately, Kurt Russell has told USA Today
that he probably won't be in the sequel, so
Burton himself sadly won't be back in action
for this one.
Nobody messes with the Jesus...except for
John Turturro, that is.
After all, Turturro played the purple-clad
Jesus in The Big Lebowski, and even though
he's only onscreen for two scenes, the pervy
bowler apparently made enough of an impression
to warrant his own spin-off movie.
Once called Going Places, it's now known as
The Jesus Rolls, and it has absolutely nothing
to do with the Dude.
"Yeah, well, that's just, you know, like,
your opinion, man."
The plot follows Jesus, who's just been released
from jail after he was framed for a crime
he didn't commit.
Now a free man, he teams up with two friends
and goes on a wild road trip.
According to the film's official plot synopsis,
the movie is:
"A film about a trio of misfits whose irreverent,
sexually charged dynamic evolves into a surprising
love story as their spontaneous and flippant
attitude towards the past or future backfires
time and again, even as they inadvertently
perform good deeds."
In September 2019, a trailer for The Jesus
Rolls appeared, albeit one dubbed in Italian
to promote the film's release in Italy.
As for the dynamic directing duo, the Coens
aren't involved with this spinoff sequel,
but they're still totally cool with Turturro
making a part two.
Almost two decades after the first Space Jam
mashed up live action comedy, Looney Tunes
animation, and professional basketball, Warner
Brothers announced in early 2014 that they'd
be making a follow up to the 1996 film.
The original Space Jam starred NBA superstar
Michael Jordan, and featured appearances from
a number of other NBA players alongside its
animated cast.
The sequel will star NBA MVP LeBron James,
in addition to Don Cheadle, fresh off his
almost decade-long stint in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
With a production team that includes Black
Panther's Ryan Coogler and The Fast and the
Furious series' Justin Lin, Space Jam 2 will
be helmed by director Malcolm D. Lee.
Lee wasn't the first director attached to
the film, though; he stepped in for Terence
Nance, who departed the production on good
terms in July 2019, citing creative differences.
The film is set to hit theaters on July 16th
2021, almost a full quarter of a century after
the first film premiered.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.